im hessischen hofheim am taunus sind die
häuser oben am hasenberg nicht an die
kanalisation angeschlossen
deshalb müssen die anwohner ihre
klärgruben abpumpen lassen immer schon
den auftrag für die arbeiten mit einem
sieg hat die stadt neu vergeben wie
folge die gebühren sind explodiert
einzelne anwohner müssen bis zu 14.000
euro zahlen
am hasenberg die die existenzangst um
wir fühlen uns absolut allein gelassen
so viel kann niemand verdienen um diese
gebühren zusätzlich bezahlen zu können
die ganze familie ist geschockt nach wie
vor wir können nachts wirklich schlecht
schlafen weil das bewegt uns alles weil
es ist wirklich existenzgefährdend man
fühlt sich verraten und verkauft wollen
die interessen von uns bürgern wurden
hier von der stadt nicht wirklich
richtig vertreten
seit über 30 jahren wohnt peter braun
schon am hasenberg das schmutzwasser
wird im garten in einer klärgrube
gesammelt die abfuhr war nie ein problem
doch im vergangenen jahr schreibt die
stadt hofheim die entsorgung neu aus und
vergibt den auftrag an ein anderes
unternehmen weil die zufahrt zum
hasenberg so eng sei sagt die stadt
dürfen nicht mehr solche großen lkw
eingesetzt werden sondern nur noch diese
kleinen die müssen aber viel öfter
fahren dadurch steigen für peter braun
die grundgebühren und obendrein wird
auch noch eine teure erschwerniszulage
fällig bei den nebenkosten sind
wohnnebenkosten monatlich von etwa 1000
euro
das kann kein mensch stämme und seinen
nachbarn geht es genauso
ronald braun drohen stolze 3400 euro
gebühren pro jahr
michael sparen muss mit 3500 euro
rechnen
und bei peter opitz thron satte 14.000
euro im hofheimer rathaus will man sich
nicht vor der kamera äußern
schriftlich heißt es man halte sich
streng an recht und gesetz
aufgrund der rechtlichen vorgaben des
kommunalen abgaben gesetzes der
entwässerungssatzung und das
vergaberecht es haben wir keine
spielräume den bürgern entgegen zu
kommen
auch hofheimer mitbürger können nicht
verstehen was die stadt davon den
anwohnern des hasen bergs verlangt
ich finde das schon unfassbar dass in
einem eigentlich die worte die
verantwortlichen sollten vielleicht
selber mal auf den hasenberg ziehen und
dort mal monatlich diese kosten tragen
dann würden sie glaube ich auch sehr
schnell nach einer lösung suchen um
gericht auf jeden fall und steht in
keinem verhältnis zu den gebühren die
die allgemeinheit bezahlt die bewohner
wehren sich gegen die bescheide und
haben widerspruch eingelegt
möglicherweise muss am ende ein gericht
über die kostenexplosion bei den
gebühren entscheiden